Jamal Bowman surrenders to police after
being charged for pulling fire alarm in
capital but oh my friends it's so much
worse we have this from RNC research
Matt Gates says this is what lawyers
would call intent y'all ready for this
one Bowman you see that here's him
walking up removing the signs knocking
on the floor pulling the fire alarm and
then walking out is anybody surprised
this guy should go to this guy should be
uh do what do we do do we impeach
members of Congress well someone uh I'll
get her name in a second but there is a
a republican House member who is wanting
to um have an official
repand I don't know if they're going to
move it to expel she filed a motion to
censure him and have him moved off
committees but like video exactly so
this video was released after can I who
can I text in be like SP
him in Congress has been expelled has
been impeached has been anything there
he should be expelled for this I mean he
should she was the one who filed the
first motion I mean it's bad did you see
his statement he released the statement
today no the the from one from this
morning being like you know I I I did
take responsibility for the fire alarm
but I'm very grateful that Capital
police agreed that I didn't do it to
disrupt the vote and republ an will spin
this you know what they're like is
essentially what it says and then this
video comes out and it's even more
obvious that it was definitely to
disrupt the vote premeditated it it
seems crazy he needs to be expelled if
the Republican majority can't expel a
member of Congress over this then the
Republican majority doesn't exist let's
see it but I mean what about Joe Biden
what about like impeaching a president
requires the Senate and it's very
difficult but this is the house with a
republican majority with they call him
magam Mike the speaker he should be
expelled first thing I mean look at this
video the thing you could with other
things it's more ambiguous to this
whatever this is a video of this guy
intentionally walking past a sign that
says this is not open knocking down
another sign and pulling a fire alarm I
just love thinking about all those like
think pieces and tweets that were sent
out after the initial story broke
defending him on why that door was
confusing it it was deeply confusing
ridiculous uh I was when I was working
on this story for Tim cast news which
you guys should all follow on the social
medias um this morning he pulls the fire
alarm then walks past Capitol Police
because he had to get to the vote but
says nothing about it because he knew
there wasn't a fire but how did you know
there wasn't a fire alarm or a real fire
if you didn't pull the alarm these
people will always lie to you they don't
care and this guy is
particularly this guy is particularly
Brazen because he's just lying over and
over again expecting you guys to buy the
well the Republicans are really the ones
who have this mess and they're so bad
like it's always about the other party
meanwhile the Republicans pulled that
fire alarm and are and the thing is like
are New Yorkers going to be upset about
enough about this like if he isn't
expelled are they going to vote him out
of office say I don't like the way
you're representing us probably not
probably not there's no accountability
on that side you know it's it's
different but like I this also made me
think of when AOC lied about the j6
stuff when she said she was being
attacked and felt like they were going
to do like horrible things to her but
then the timeline broke it down and it
wasn't possible even where through the
tunnels and where she was and all that
stuff they will get away with anything
they can lie to us we can see videos we
understand what's going on but the
people at large media they can get away
with it they help them get away with it
they'll write stories in defense of the
still right they have the right letter
at the end of their name so everyone
will fall it's the same thing with the
pavlac do and the world colonizers
Republicans will do nothing I mean look
props to Matt gates for doing anything
when it comes to McCarthy just getting
something done but I don't see them
taking a meaningful action like yo this
this course of action where you see him
take down these signs and then pull the
fire alarm is an intent to disrupt
official government proceedings it is a
threat to our
democracy he's got he's got to he's got
to be removed if this kind of behavior
is allowed to continue it will escalate
and we are dangerously close to the
point where finally someone in Congress
just snaps and then someone else snaps
and then all a sudden someone's getting
caned and that's the last thing we want
to happen yeah this is this is just as
bad as Pearl Harbor you know that's what
the Democrats would say if it was Jim
Jordan doing it yeah well if it was Jim
Jordan oh if if a republican did this
front page of every newspaper world will
be over oh yes it be done several
inquiries would be launched lots of lots
of special money the GOP leadership
would apologize for having oh 100% And
they would announce censure and the
removal from committees yeah Y no he'll
get away with it he's fine no he's
protected that's why I'm glad the video
came out right like I am glad that the
second this happened this is I am
cynical a lot a lot of about a lot of
social media and we do need to verify
things but when this happened they were
in Congress for this like stop Gap
budget vote or whatever and the video
came out over the weekend by Monday
there was a narrative there were lots of
public condemnations from the the
Republicans you know it was kind of
obvious what had happened and then the
second he goes to court the next time he
goes to court is I think January uh
because okay so sorry one thought at a
time so he goes to court accepts this
plea deal where he is going to pay a
$5,000 or $1,000 fine he's going to
write in a letter of apology to the
chief of the Capitol Police and then if
he doesn't break any more laws this will
all be uh dropped 3 months from now
that's why he goes back in January and
if it had been a republican they would
never let this happen and also the
second he accepts the plea deal we get
another video about an even more blatant
like it's even more clear what was going
on and so as much as I think social
media can work perspective or you
shouldn't share videos that aren't
verified it is interesting that he gets
a very sweet deal and as soon as we
think it's about to fall go under the
rug someone out there is like no you
guys really need to see what happened
and that's that's a good use of Twitter
in my opin oh I know I agree for all the
bad stuff that we we see on Twitter I
don't want to suppress you know a lot of
the people sharing false news although I
think it's ridiculous that they do it um
but I like the debates that it starts
because it's been for for me fun writing
about the way people are reacting to
these things whether it's in our Journal
journalism sphere or just people at
large you know the way they uh the way
they're interpreting reality is so
different even with something like this
this maybe not so much but you know I
think of The Written House video or the
George Floyd video and the way we all
look at that video and have way
different interpretations even though it
looks like it's a it should be objective
reality yeah but depending on what
political persuasion you are 30 seconds
before after is included oh yeah for
sure uh how does war room handle stuff
like this like do you guys play videos
that you find on Twitter do you have a
verification
process I think I mentioned this like
before we started we don't cover
probably about 80% of this kind of news
that goes on yeah so like uh what Steve
like to say is like chasing the shiny
toys and so you know we try to focus on
you know for example the speaker race
and just like the really nitty-gritty of
just what's going on and so not to be
distracted I mean not saying that this
isn't important it's important but um
you know not to lose focus on you know
uh the new speaker or you guys have more
of a narrowed view so when this happened
did you guys talk about it at all or
were you still focused more on the
budget we're just on getting the right
speaker making sure that the posi is
calling every single moment um voicing
their opinion you know like all of this
stuff is great and and it's you know
like but for us we don't focus on that
we want to make sure that you know
because after the speaker vote we've got
a whole another job ahead of us to make
sure that the speaker you know aligns
with everything that we want you know
him to do so so so that's why um it was
funny cuz I was telling Steve I'm like
I'm like they talk about current events
I need to go out like look on current
events and Steve was like Grace just be
blunt and just tell them you know that
um that we focus on you know like the
speaker stuff and we talked about the
'90s which you guys know all about
Steve's big on uh Singularity stuff
though very big on Singularity yes shout
out to Joe Allen who might be watching
right now a good friend yes he's a very
good friend of mine and you guys should
have him on oh you guys had him on last
time we have his book his book yes oh my
God yes it's right there right there
dark he's a great guy he was with us in
Miami he came to the event yes he was
there yeah yeah yeah we are uh good guy
people should understand what the
singularity means the moment the moment
the AI generates the ability to improve
itself it's like thousands of years of
human development to create an AI and
then a fraction of a second where the AI
exponentially magnifies itself yes and
becomes something beyond beyond our
comprehension I think we're almost so I
have his book and I like I tell Joe and
I'm
like I'm really scared to read it to be
honest like it's a big book yeah it's a
big book but but um but no I mean it's
important topic it's a very important
topic and you know what one thing that
like War Room really Prides ourselves on
is just being a ahead you know like 6
months a year ahead and um yeah talking
about the future and the singularity
neuralink all that stuff the marriage
with with Machinery I mean even a like
I'm telling you even the app I mean uh
full disclaimer I mean I use chap chat
GPT if Joe's watching I hope he's
sicking he's mad at me yeah yeah yeah no
but I wanted to I mean it that's the
thing why cuz it makes it chat GPT and
Tik Tok who is this woman no I mean it
it's that's the where it's way it's
going I I I think it's fascinating that
we have hypothesized exactly what AI is
going to do and it's going to do it and
we know it's going to do it and that is
we'll create a robocar for instance and
say your job is to get person from point
A to point B and then robocar will say
the fastest way to do that is to go 300
miles an hour y you know speed limits
are inhibiting the the the system then
they'll try to shut it down and they'll
say shutting me down inhibits the system
we know that this kind of thing will
eventually happen no matter what yep yes
the machine will eventually decide that
human interaction is a detriment to it
system because humans are imperfect in
how they code these things they won't be
able to predict the loopholes that will
occur in the in in the algorithms yeah I
don't think there's any turning back
from it now which is what's scary why
I'm sooner than we thought and yeah and
probably we even know right now I mean
the stuff that's reaching the consumer
Market is not the most G you can just
like hey can I have a business model to
create some sort of business boom it's
right there to be fair though Chad GPT
is so obstructed by wokeness that it's
it's it's useless it just it is like uh
mid journey is great because you it can
help you conceptualize things but chat
GPT I find to be almost useless because
it doesn't actually ever tell you
anything think about how fast mid
Journey has changed in the in the year
you know of using it um I I don't know
it's scary to me I I think there's like
transhumanists who really like the idea
of neurolink like Ray kwi you know and
they they want to upload their
Consciousness and be a
uh forever and that's a thing I worry
about in the future I literally might
have to have a fight with my kids on
them wanting to be immortal and it's not
well watch watch instead of sneaking out
it's bra there's that show called upload
and it's pretty good but it just
basically turns into leftist propaganda
and it's kind of laughable but like we
know the show is the the show is uh when
you're before or after you die you can
upload your brain your Consciousness
into the into the the digital universes
and in the latest season spoilers
everybody I don't know if you're
watching it but I'm G spoil it for you
there's uh to have the luxury afterlife
it's very expensive and you got to keep
paying and as soon as you can't pay
you're gone and for the people who are
broke you get this like pay you know pay
per megabyte system where you freeze
until someone reloads you and then you
can start moving again you don't time
jumps for you and then so they try to
create a free open source version where
you can upload your Consciousness to
this open source world and uh the it's
it's a it's a plot by the billionaires
to just murder like 10 million
po people byon uploading them into a
system that doesn't actually exist and
then destroying it all like that's
that's but I would I would only just say
you can't upload your Consciousness it's
not possible all you'll be able to do is
create a demonic fimile of your
personality that will imitate you long
after you're dead and burning in hell
right do people feel called to be like
the first to do this like does anyone
feel like this is
something when when the when the
implants first came out there were viral
videos news reports of people being like
I'm so excited to get the chip implanted
in my
hand it never got implemented right so
these people who are so excited about
walking up to the door and then scanning
their hand it only was like three
buildings they were ever able to use and
now they got the stupid thing stuck in
them right yeah I mean and and neuralink
just got approved by the FDA for human
trials after a lot of failed tests with
animals and I'm I've been imploring Elon
Musk for a long time on Twitter to I
would love to do an interview with you
about nurlink he said multiple times he
hasn't done a technical interview about
neuralink I would really really like to
sit with him and talk about the future
of neuralink because it's very
interesting to me what they're doing
with neur link right now is curing the
blind the deaf and the paralyzed I know
cuz there's a lot of beautiful things
that they are doing but the consequences
into deep in the future I good campaign
out first but where do you draw the line
that's the thing it's like it's a
beautiful thing that they can give sight
to the Blind and all these things or or
make a wounded veteran walk again
however the Deep future consequences of
that are terrifying and for every time
time they get it right how many times
they get it wrong and they're not
telling you about someone who is deeply
harmed by it I know you mean like how
many astronauts went to the moon and
never came back oh now we're talking but
like this is the interesting thing about
the human brain and technology and like
space as part of that right there there
are people who feel called No Matter
What to push forward and in some ways
that feels very admirable to the human
Spirit it like reminds me of when people
are going west and their covered wagons
and the opportunity and all of that and
I I like that aspect of it but I don't
trust the technology and I don't trust
our ability to you know obviously like
the reason pan door's box such a saying
you can't put it back right we can't put
these things back if we decide oh we
made a mistake theoretically we could
have been like oh don't don't go into
that Forest you know this this area is
not able to be settled but we can't do
that with technology and the problem
with neuralink oh there's lots uh is
that at some point you will be left out
of the modern world if you don't have it
so they'll say like the you have a
choice to get or not but like if you
don't have a a smartphone these days
you're kind of left out I'm kind of
veering away from that world I'm kind of
starting to reject a lot of it although
it's going to be hard with the work we
well and this was the thing with uh any
calls to make the internet a utility
right because you can't live life
without it and so therefore you should
have it I mean what if you don't want
the internet what if you don't want the
neur link was there was one interview
that I saw which was with um I don't
know if you guys know Josh he just
passed away he was
quadriplegic I don't think so awesome
awesome influencer just like great guy
and um he had an interview with Joe
Allen and
um he had asked you know like am I you
know he he talked about getting nurlink
and you know it's very controversial and
stuff and and that was one of the
interviews where I was just so torn and
it was I can tell it was just you know
like I mean he he recently passed away
and that was his question like am I
candidate you know to get neuralink
right I know and oh sorry I was just
saying the moral the moral part of this
is like me being really against it and
then like what people would ask me like
what if your kid gets really really
wounded and and that's the only way to
fix it it's it's a really really
complicated conversation um but again I
do find there's beautiful aspects to
repairing people it's a pretty wild
invention it's the stuff that's going to
happen deep after that that will and
then I go back to my whole point of who
legislates that Congress I and they
can't even do Facebook right yeah you
can't trust it yeah thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8:00 pm and become a member
over at timcast.net